les filles Trinon au mariage aux hommes
au fêtes et pas forcément dans cet
an maises chéri nous passerons toujours
en
premier il semblerait que pour les
jeunes filles d'un certain raffinement
New York soit devenue tropité je suis
tout à fait d'accord je vous invite à
venir avec vos filles à Londres à
Londres Londres Londres le bal des
débutantes les amécains rich je suis s
qu'ils ont des manières abominbl nous
n'avons plus qu'à serrer les dents et
penser à sa fortune TR un nouveau monde
redress les épes tte haute n jamais peur
de rienz m'excuser je suis désolé je
m'appelle n à peine revenu de New York
imaginez une romance passionnée avec un
beau lordanglais il est évident que ça
ne t'intéresse pas du tout d'être admiré
c'est une chose que je peux très bien
faire toute
seule
on dirait du bétail vous êtes plutôt dur
je les trouve charmante oui mais ce sont
des êtres humains qui sont drôles et
spiritu les filles que je CTOI ne
pensent pas et ne parlent pas avec
autant de liberté ni avec autant de
passion imaginez ne pas réaliser êre en
présence d'un duc c'est encore une de
vous
quoi donne-moi une seule bonne raison
qui t'empêcherait d'être duchesse il est
impossible d'ailleurs c'est quoi une
duchesse
voici mon plus vieil ami tu la connais
[Musique]
se déplace d'une façon tout à fait
surprenante que une histoire n'est pas
une histoire d'amour c'est une
tragédie on est
ensemble
Ginny et si c'était le grand
[Musique]
amour bonté divine quelle Lady vous
faites la Lady que j'ai toujours voulu
[Musique]
devenir